foreign
[Music]
here today we are going to talk about
the future of the DCU DC Universe and
how we believe it's going to be the
biggest year yet for the DC Universe one
that could finally rival the MCU mark my
words end of 2023 you will be agreeing
with Greg John how are you I am excited
to talk about this I'm doing well sir
how are you doing well doing well ladies
and gentlemen Shazam that like button if
you can smash it do whatever you got to
do to do it so we're going to talk about
several things today and uh some several
things some several things those proper
proper wording in sentences we're gonna
talk about updates in the DCU upcoming
movies updates on James Gunn and Peter
saffron taking over Black Adam Shazam
Henry Cavill updates there's always a
whole bunch to go through and it's all
just making me that much more excited
for 2023 and what the DC Universe has to
offer so first thing on the list we got
to go over that is for sure an
indication of this could be like their
most financially successful year to date
is they do have four movies officially
coming in 2023 we have Shazam 2 Fury of
the Gods The Flash movie Blue Beetle and
Aquaman and the lost kingdom and Aquaman
one that already hit a billion dollars
so if there's one of these that they're
looking to possibly make a billion
dollars it could be Aquaman and the lost
kingdom but that's that's got to be at
least a couple billion right there you
know what I mean that's a movie every
quarter I mean like the fortunate thing
about the position they're in now is
that you know the superhero movie
Machine pumps out so many a year that
they can easily catch up in little time
with all these things which one are you
most successful John I want to see sholo
maraduena as the Blue Beetle I want
something new and I'm excited to see
what he brings to that me The Flash
movie Yes
flash two uh so yeah I mean we have
confirmation of those four movies coming
out in conjunction with each other and I
wanted to point that out first because
what we have here is from CEO David
zosloff everyone's greatest hero right
now give it up
let's do this
I got a iffy emotional association with
the guy yeah
I can't imagine why but I'm excited
about James going to Peter saffron to
say the least so there was recently an
earnings call and there's this quote
that's been going around I'll read it
for you right now I've spent a lot of
time over the past few months with James
and Peter which I find interesting that
he's saying that because you know like
it wasn't that long ago when he took
over and it seems like he's had this
kind of in development from the
beginning talking about our strategy and
long-term plans for the future of DC
across TV animation and film they have a
powerful vision and blueprint that will
drive a more unified creative approach
that will allow us to enable to the full
value of one of the world's most iconic
franchises they are hard at work right
now meaning that seems like that 10-year
plan or whatever the heck it was at
Davis office season looks like they
might actually have something in the
world they might have an actual plan now
of what they might want to do so when
thinking about this I was like okay
we're looking at the release dates of
these four movies and now when you have
The Flash coming out in June a month
after that is usually Comic-Con and they
can make a big splash at sdcc
too many Z's they can make a big splash
there with their announcements of what
they have upcoming with whatever the
plan is that's being formulated
following the success of their
Multiverse movie The Flash and whatever
that does with creating timelines or
whatever mojomo comes down the road but
bottom line is they could do that or if
they'd wait after Blue Beetle but before
Aquaman the lost kingdom usually that
time in October is when they would have
the DC fandom where they can make an
even bigger Splash right then and there
maybe they might even show up at sdcc
and DC fandom but if they have this plan
that they put into fruition because
they'd have to work with these four
films I think right then and there you
know because when you think about the
idea of these four movies coming out
four movies that are more than likely
going to be big box office hits if
there's one thing us comic book movie
fans love more than anything else it's
the anticipation the hiking me those
juicy details things give me those few
talking points the future
vehicle on every site that's what we
love more than anything else it's the
thing to look forward to the trickles of
what comes next rather than the actual
product yeah so with that in mind if
you're having actual products coming out
that are being big hits and then
whatever shows they have that are also
big hits I'm assuming penguin Joe has to
come at some point and then you have
these announcements that alone could
generate the biggest year for 2023.
Jonathan oh yeah I mean the the good
thing again about this is that like the
world is their oyster the playing field
is Theirs to gain on and so I feel like
if they could show up at sdcc and then
you know come back with the DC fandom
that Rivals that of the first DC fandom
they could have a huge mic drop of a
year in 2020 23 and plus it says right
there TV movies and animation and one
thing DC is great at I think most people
agree is they're animated movies and
they have some legendary and prolific TV
projects as well so if they could bring
all that stuff together and really you
know you've got HBO caliber shows coming
up from this universe that we already
have experience with I feel like that is
a great blend of things to get people
excited and to get this universe if not
back on top at least back in a place
where it is commanding the full respect
it deserves yeah that's why they got to
keep canceling shows that nobody likes
at death that's right nobody likes star
girl no one has ever liked star girl no
it's really sad what happened there's a
lot of things
but there's a lot of things to be
hopeful for too I met a guy who works on
a pretty big WB show and he says the
crew is constantly stressed about the
Futures oh I can't so as much as this is
a positive video about the DCU I am also
going to say that I'm aware that you
know and there could be some rocky roads
ahead this is one of many regime changes
and it's just we'll see how this one
goes but it seems like they've picked
the right people so I have faith I want
to embrace a tad bit of optimism yeah
and then uh one thing I do want to talk
about that I think should be something
that people ought to get excited about I
want to quickly go over a dramatic
report other people have done videos
about it this week already you guys
might have already heard about Dwayne
Johnson's thinly veiled disdain first
the Shazam movies and perhaps even the
character what's been coming out the
long story short without going into
every single quote is that there was a
deleted scene from Shazam that has
reportedly surfaced that tease Black
Adam showing up in a Shazam Sequel and
Dwayne Johnson wanted that scene to be
removed reports about him having this
thinly failed the Zane disdain the
reports about him having a thinly veiled
the stain and also the fact that Peter
saffron produces Shazam so that could
create some potential friction but
Dwayne Johnson himself has come out and
said that no it's inevitability they win
will eventually cross over together and
I think there's one thing Dwayne Johnson
has proven with Black Adam whether you
love that film or not he really does
care about the fans and he really does
listen to the fans and if he's gonna
work his ass off to make sure Superman
can show up and granted he obviously
seems way more excited at the prospect
of a film between him and Superman than
he does between him and Shazam clearly
people want him to go toe-to-toe with
Shazam they want something there to
happen so I don't think Dwayne Johnson
the guy who's notoriously known for
listening to his fans I don't think he's
gonna completely ignore his fans and
there has been a rumor a report coming
out that there is a scene or
post-credits scene I don't know if
there's a spell or not just a rumor that
they are going to include Black Adam in
the Shazam Fury of the Gods in some way
yeah I mean that would make a lot of
sense and yeah given what The Rock has
said on record I feel like it's just
about finessing the project so that they
can Co coalesce together in a way that
makes sense and I feel like the position
you're in with Shazam as it reads to me
is partly that you have this character
who is growing and maturing and I feel
like at a third or fourth movie is the
more appropriate time to have him meet a
character like Black Adam and if you
look at Black Adam there is a sense of
humor in that movie that is darker but
still akin to what you would see in a
Shazam so I feel like he's well aware
that yeah the source material merits
them coming together and I don't think
he has any begrudging quality towards
that so I think it's mostly about taking
the right time to do it rather than
rushing it and that seems to be his
whole approach this this entire time a
thousand percent and of course you know
we gotta talk about any minor update
from Henry Cavill it's about as good as
Hugh Jackman updating us on Deadpool 3
which is it's happening and I'm excited
so in Henry Cavill he's giving like
these quotes out there lately but
there's one in particular there's an
excerpt from one of his very long quotes
because he's just been expressing lately
how excited he is that he's just gonna
be back here he even talked crazy
recently about how he hasn't met James
Gunn yet but he's excited to be having
these future ongoing conversations with
him about the future of Superman within
the DC Universe but what he said
recently is that but it is humbling to
be the guy who gets to be the custodian
of that character once again and
hopefully for many years to come as long
as I do Justice by the character so if
he's putting out words like that it
could just be him putting out wishful
thinking or this hopefulness which is
very Superman but putting out this
hopefulness of I want to do more than
just like a couple of films or whatever
like I really want to have a long-term
game here with Superman I think for him
to be putting it out there's gotta at
least be some conversations going
forward now about what it is the future
of Superman will be with Henry Cavill
and how long can they gestate that you
know what I mean yeah yeah how can they
gracefully grow this into something that
can stick around for a long time and
carry that weight and cultural iconic
importance I guess because there has
been such a journey in a road with him
and it's really gratifying and it does
seem like the perfect example of a guy
who is completely suited to the
character and they would be foolish not
to make everything they can out of the
second chance that this is because you
know people are gonna people are already
petitioning for him to be reinstated as
geralt like people who love Henry
cavill's characters and if he could
really bounce back and really put the
definitive Spirit of Superman stamp on
it I feel like that will alone Bowie the
DC Universe for many years to come uh I
think he should come back as girl he
should I feel bad for Liam Emsworth but
I'm like no he's he's my favorite
character no no no yeah I can't imagine
not him don't want to watch it I want to
watch it for morbid curiosity I would
like to watch one episode but I yes
that's fair enough I agree
alrighty guys well there we are with the
DC Universe what are you most excited
about with the future of this franchise
yeah just wanted to put that out there
really quick and uh share some optimism
about it because I'm I'm starting to
fill out all right guys well subscribe
leave a like hey let's send this for the
patreon
Lance door Lance it's Thanksgiving time
and uh we're kicking off this month
we're acknowledging our
longest most loyal supporters by far you
want you guys want to know how long of a
like how loyal to support this guy is he
has not swayed from the amount pledged
that he has on her patreon page for a
total of
57 months it's almost five years watch
me do the math watch me do the math
that's not fun is it that is like five
years yeah I got the patreon for five
years
oh that's crazy uh so Lance what are you
gonna do today
365 times five
five two
uh one thousand seven hundred twenty
five plus seven months I I don't know
how long
at first I saw it I was like 57 months
it's like a little over a year no no
wait that's how many weeks though
12 times sixes
is uh is no no no oh no I'm getting what
are you talking about
yeah like four years twelve times five
is sixty yeah there you go
that's a long time Lance what are you
doing with your life is something that
could have accrued and been able to
generate a real profit out could have
bought a few shares of a modest stock
and watched it grow crypto you'd be a
million oh dude you would yeah and then
you'd lose it and then become a
millionaire again and ride that roller
coaster to your grave but I appreciate
you being here for as long as you have
been man it's uh it's a very very nice
support So Lance I hope you have a
wonderful Thanksgiving and know that we
are extremely grateful for you and your
presence thank you buddy
[Music]